hi everyone
in this talk i'm going to talk about
what lies in word embeddings
but before we go in depth in word
embeddings let's consider
a quick experiment that we can just go
ahead and do what i can do is i can
download
some news headlines and these news
headlines might have text in it
something like good weather
and what i can do is i can train a deep
learning system
to predict the next character so for
example
looking at a headline like this it
starts with the letter g
and then i get the letter o then i get
the letter o
letter o again then an o and a d
a d and then a space that you would have
right here
etc but what i can do just for the
experiment
is i can train myself a neural network
to predict the next letter
and here's the architecture that you
might use to go about that
you start with a character let's say at
position t that's somewhere along the
title
and that character can be represented as
a 37 dimensional one hot encoded array
i have 26 letters i have 10 numbers and
i've got the white space character
so i only need 37 indices to represent
all the letters
now next what i can do is i can hook
that up to let's say a feed forward
layer
and after this i would have another feed
forward layer
and let's say that this feed forward
layer has an activation function
something like softmax maybe such that
the outputs on the final layer sum up to
one
and then the goal is that the final
layer represents our predictions
for the next character so what's going
to happen now is that
because on this side i've got an input
and because on this side i've got an
output
i can calculate what sort of errors i'm
making
and this gives me a gradient
signal that's going to move back
from the output updating this feed
forward layer
and that's going to propagate and update
this feed forward layer
and what's relatively interesting about
this is that this model kind of gives us
two outputs if you think about it
the first output are of course these
probabilities and these classifications
but let's say now that i've got
a two-dimensional array over here
then i also have this
representation of a character internally
it's this
compressed floating point array that
should have a lot of information about
you know the characters that i put in
here and this is something that people
like to call an embedding
so what i'm going to do is just show you
what's happening when we actually
run this training procedure so here's a
visualization of both the embedding
and the predictions over here you see
predictions that are being made
given this letter coming in then this is
the letter that we're predicting and the
more yellow it is the higher the
probability
and over here you see how every letter
is sort of
projected in this two-dimensional space
now it's a bit random now because the
neural network hasn't
trained on anything just yet hasn't seen
any data but what i'm about to do is i'm
about to
hit the train button and then we'll see
how over time
this image and this image is going to
update
just to see what happens both to the
internal representation of a letter
and to the predictions that go out
you should now see that things are
updating this guy over here is
converging
but the more interesting thing is
actually happening on this side
we are starting to see clusters appear
by adding this i would argue somewhat
artificial label we're just predicting
the next token
but by adding that we have a training
procedure to go
from a letter to a two-dimensional
representation
and if you squint your eyes you'll
notice that there's some
interesting clusters that appear from
the get-go
we can see that all the vowels and
consonants are separate there's a little
cluster over here with all sorts of
numbers
and we also see that the white character
or the space bar
also is sort of its own region so to say
so we have
somewhat logical clusters and what i can
also do
is i can start playing around with what
kind of clusters that i might get
what i can do is i can add more or less
data and see if i get slightly different
kinds of clusters
so here's another example of some of
these
clusters that have been created and
again we see similar clusters but they
are in a different place
so all the letters are over here vowels
and consonants are separate
the numbers are over here and again the
white space again has its own region
one thing that we can see here is that
by introducing this
fake label so to say we have found
ourselves a
interesting unsupervised method of
clustering letters
and the fact that this works for letters
can make us wonder
can we do maybe a similar thing for
words
just like a letter is part of a word a
word is part of a sentence
or a paragraph or a document and it
might be possible that by using a
similar method
we can get similar properties however
a very important question to ask
ourselves at this point in time
what lies in these word embeddings
we're going to maybe want to do this in
higher dimensions for words
so we got to start wondering what
properties can we actually expect when
we do this
and while we explore what lies in word
embeddings i hope that you recognize
that there are
two interpretations of this word
so let's now say we're gonna go ahead
and start training the system
not for letters but for proper word
embeddings then we should recognize that
a couple of things are definitely
different
for starters we're not gonna have 37 odd
tokens here
that's not going to cut it instead it's
more likely that we have
let's say starting from 20 000 tokens
here probably a lot more
and for a very similar reason we're
probably not going to have
two dimensions here odds are that we
might go for something more like 300.
if you think about all the different
clusters that we might get with
actual words instead of just letters
then two dimensions might not be enough
space to compress
all that information in another thing
that's bound to be different
is this label over here again we're not
going to have
37 tokens it's more like 20 000
so this label over here probably also
will have many more outputs
let's say that someone somewhere took
the effort of actually doing this
on a huge data set with lots of compute
power
that means that we have a very
convenient mapping from
this word to this vector for that word
and the idea and kind of the hope is
that that vector
summarizes a lot of information about
that word
what we've effectively built is some
sort of system that can take
text and can give us a numeric
representation
this is what the embedding does and this
is also
where we can sort of draw the line where
we say this is something that you can
pre-compute
and then let's say that you have a
custom task the hope is
that you can take this pre-computed
numeric representation
and then maybe the only thing you need
is to put a support vector machine in
here
plus your own labels and the hope is if
this numeric representation if that
indeed has been trained on something
that's very big and very general
then maybe your custom task is much
easier to solve
the hope is that during this pre-compute
step someone has been
able to compress all relevant
information down into a vector
such as the only thing you need to do is
to just put one
extra layer of training after it with
your own labels
this was the dream at least that was
announced when people first started
doing this
unfortunately though it's really not
perfect
so let's not talk about the use case
where these embeddings fall short
i work for a company called raza and we
make open source tools
to help anyone make conversational
agents that perform very well under a
wide range of circumstances
one thing that we see all the time is
spelling errors
for example someone doesn't type
university but instead types univer
city another way to describe a spelling
error in this case
is to look at it as a out of vocabulary
situation
the issue is that this way of spelling
maybe didn't occur in our training data
and therefore we will not have an index
for it in our sparse array
and that can have the consequence that
the embedding that we have for it
will just be a dense vector that just
contains zeros
there's a couple of ways you can deal
with this at raza a very common trick is
to just use
count vectors that use engrams what we
can do is we can say well
let's just for example look at the
trigrams of
university here's some examples if we
can
have a one hut encoded representation of
those and pass those along to our
machine learning pipeline
instead of just these dense vectors then
we are a little bit more robust against
these phenomena that said embeddings can
use a very similar trick
because you can take these trigrams and
use those as input
the idea behind this is that if you have
let's say university in your training
example
then you can separate that into sub
tokens that each will go into the sparse
array
and then it's up to the gradient update
to make sure that these weights
are all have an appropriate value but
you would still get this one-to-one
mapping from
a word to a vector
in this case should for whatever reason
there be a spelling error
and let's say this word here would be
different
then what would effectively happen is
maybe some of these trigrams would go
away
let's say maybe this one and whenever
this happens you might lose some
information
but you wouldn't lose all the
information so it would still be your
bust against
some spelling errors or some out of
vocabulary tokens
if you look online you can find an
implementation called fast text
and it has about 150 pre-trained
languages with this property attached
it's trained using sub-tokens the main
downside of the approach is that because
you have to train for all of these
separate sub-tokens
that the embeddings themselves can be
six to seven gigabytes big but there is
another trick that you can do
to maybe get support embeddings that are
a bit more lightweight
i've written down some words and let's
think about them
if i want to represent them do i really
need to have all of the trigrams or
engrams
or can it maybe be a bit more clever
that i only take certain sub words out
of all the possible ones
in particular if i have a look at these
words i hope you would agree that
for all of these professions and
sciences the first part of the word
explains what kind of science it is and
the second part of the word represents
whether we're talking about the person
doing the science or the science itself
you can kind of look at these words as
if they have morphological features that
a lot of these words can have meaning
because it's basically a combinations of
two other meanings
and you can imagine that we do this
pre-processing procedure where
we look at the english language and we
just do this compression technique where
we just ask
hey what might be an effective subword
allocation
given that we only want to have 30 000
subwords
please find the ones that are the most
effective
they cover the most ground and there's
this byte pair technique
that can do that pre-processing
beforehand for you
and once you have that you will have
another list
of sub words like astro
geo topo g and
just let's say let's pretend that these
are the sub words and then you can still
encode those just like before
these embeddings also exist they are
known as bipair embeddings
and these have been pre-trained in over
275 languages
and you can get these in much smaller or
much bigger sizes if you're interested
some of these embeddings are just
megabytes so this can be seen as a
lightweight variant of fast text so i
hope with these explanations it's clear
how these embeddings came to be
but we maybe now should start talking
about some of the properties that they
may or may not possess
figuring out what information exactly is
encoded in a
300 dimensional array is tricky also
there's many different pre-trained
languages out there so
what i've done in the past year is i've
made this tool
called what lies it's a tool that helps
explain
what lies in these word embeddings and
although i won't be doing a tutorial
here
i will use it to demonstrate some
properties that you can expect
from these word embeddings in particular
what i'm doing here
is i am using what lies to fetch me some
information from spacey
i am taking their english core language
and i'm just
asking it to fetch me similar
tokens to university the way that's
happening right now
is i'm saying well let's just take two
vectors and
let's look at this angle between them
and this is happening in 300 dimensions
but that angle between those two vectors
that is known as a cosine distance and
based on that i'm asking fetch me the
similar
tokens and you see here that when you
use spacey
university is fine it can fetch things
that are reasonable
the moment you make a spelling error it
suddenly becomes very hard to get
anything reasonable
basically because spacey will assign a
vector of zeros to this token right now
if i would do the same thing with fast
text the results will be different
here are the examples without the
spelling error and here are the examples
with the spelling error one thing you'll
notice is that the distances here in
general
are definitely bigger but despite these
bigger distances
we do see lots of reasonable results
coming back here it's better than spacey
when it comes to this task
if you further squint your eyes you're
going to see something that's
interesting
notice that universities if you misspell
it it suddenly has cities as a subword
in there if you have a look at some of
the words that we get back
places arena
countries venues then it seems that
fastex is able to recover to some degree
so i thought this example was nice
because it does really show how
subward embeddings can be useful but
it's still a mixed bag and
if you're not careful what i'm doing
after is i'm doing the same thing with
bipair embeddings
and here you see the bytepair is
actually having a fair bit of difficulty
here
apparently the subwords that were chosen
don't fit this particular use case too
well
so you could say that fast text can be
better in this particular case
but there are situations where you have
out of vocabulary words
where suddenly byte parent performs a
lot better the example that i like to
use to show this
is the zergling mitosis word the main
thing i would like to emphasize here
is that zergling mitosis it's a word
that totally doesn't exist
but i hope that you would agree that
because of the mitosis
at the end of the word as a human i
might think ah it's
probably something of a disease and the
interesting thing here is that
pair gets this way better than fast text
if you look at the byte pair results
over here at the bottom it seems that
the way that it's working
is it's able to zoom in on only this
mitosis part
probably what's happening here is that
this mitosis subword
is one of the sub words that bypair was
able to train on
and it's ignoring everything else in the
word fast text cannot do that
fast x will actually look at all the
engrams that it has in its vocabulary
and it will try to do something with it
and what i think is happening in this
case is that because we have a capital
letter over here
fasttex is sort of assuming that this is
probably a name of a person
which is why we see johnson and barry
and wilson
so these support embeddings they can
help
with this out of vocabulary situation
but we do need to be careful
because they're definitely not perfect
and
speaking of not being perfect let's talk
about what we're actually doing here
when we retrieve items that are similar
in embedded space
does that mean that we are retrieving
items that have the same meaning
the answer is a resounding no that's
totally not what's happening
and a really good example of that is to
fetch words like
fast and slow because
as far as embedded space goes slow and
fast are really really similar
if you think about how the words are
being used in a sentence they are really
similar
they describe the speed of something so
grammatically if you were to replace the
word fast with the word slow
it would still be a grammatically
correct sentence
however words that are really similar in
embedded space
they can be opposites of each other as
far as meaning goes
these word embeddings simply do not
represent
meaning of a word they represent how a
word is typically being used in a
sentence
which is a proxy for meaning but it's
certainly
a different thing and it's important to
get that right
if you're going to be using these
pre-trained embeddings
in your machine learning pipeline then
you should be aware that
because it's not representing actual
meaning then it might be representing
something that you don't want
so let's talk about bias what i'm
showing you here is a similarity chart
and one thing that we can see for
example is that the word woman
and the word nurse seem to have a larger
similarity
than man and nurse
and if you squint your eyes a little bit
you'll also see that man is a little bit
more similar to programmer
than woman and here's where the danger
can happen
suppose that these are my words and that
they live in 2d space
well then one thing that will be highly
unfortunate
is if the direction from man to woman
correlates a little bit with the
direction from programmer to nurse
however i do hope that you agree that
language in general is not
unbiased so if there's bias in the data
odds are that our embeddings might be
picking that up
and amplifying it if i were to maybe
train a resume classifier or something
like that
then there's a risk that there's going
to be a decision boundary
kind of along an axis where men get
one type of job and women get another
type of job and this is really dangerous
because
there is no reason why a man couldn't be
a nurse or why a woman couldn't be a
programmer
but this is something to really take
serious
and just for good measure it is
relatively easy
to make a visualization like this that
will help to convince you
that indeed we can measure that this
bias is somehow in these embeddings
if you take a look at the direction from
nurse to physician that's a direction in
embedded space
and it seems that that direction is
quite similar to the direction of mother
father
now if i'm thinking about the actual
meaning of the word
that should not happen however since
these embeddings
are merely learning how these words are
being used
we do have this recipe for a dangerous
scenario happening
if we're not careful there are some
de-biasing techniques
that try to mitigate this bias however
the ones that i've tried so far all seem
to fail
and i just want to spend a little bit of
time explaining how this is happening
and why
so here's how a devising technique might
work
let's say that we've got this axis
from man to woman let's say and the main
concern that we have
is that potentially the access from
programmer to nurse is similar
one linear algebra trick that we could
do is we could say well let's take that
axis
let's have it go through the origin and
let's now make a projection that's
at 90 degrees with that
so this is a 90 degree angle right there
now the idea here is that if this axis
were actually to represent gender
everything on this line would have
gender
equal to zero and theoretically that
means that i might be able to just go
ahead
and project words down onto that axis
and the hope is that by moving these
points
this way that you might be able to
remove
some of the gender bias because
in this case right man woman it's closer
together
and programmer and nurse are also closer
together so we might have been able to
remove a lot of bias
and in fact we can quantify this to some
extent
let's say that we take our 300
dimensions and we actually apply this
trick
we calculate the gender axis calculate a
plane
project everything onto that plane and
hope for the best
then i can indeed quantify that this
correlation that i had before is now
much less
and we could convince ourselves right
now that hey
there's an improvement we can report
that we're doing a good thing
but here is where you have to be super
careful there's still plenty of bias
left even though this one metric is
reporting a good improvement
and it's not just the fact that we're
only considering gender here
the real issue is that we've barely
changed the internal representation
to understand that we have to consider
how word embeddings are used in practice
in practice word embeddings are used
kind of as a pre-processing step
you have words that you start out with
then you pass it along to something like
fast text
and then you get this numeric
representation that you can give to a
psychic learn model and then
use to make a prediction note that doing
this in scikit-learn
is made a whole lot easier by this for
lice package as well
every language back-end that we support
is also usable
as a featurizer inside of psychic learn
so by pair
fast text spacey hugging face all of
those
you can just use directly here it also
means that we can do a bit of an
experiment
what i can do is i can create a data set
where
half the words are super masculine and
other words are super feminine
man woman king queen these kinds of
words words where there's definitely a
gender attached
and what i can do is i can train this
pipeline and then report
on how well my test set is being
predicted
when i do that without concerning myself
about de-biasing
i get about a 90 accuracy on my test set
but now let's say i make a small change
now let's say that
i'm keeping my train set as is but this
test set
that is going to be the biased using the
technique that i mentioned before
so we're going to be doing lots of these
projections and then this d
biased set that is what i'll be using
to predict now if this trick were to
work
now if we actually did proper devising i
hope you would agree that i would get
maybe a
50 accuracy now because i'm removing all
the gender information
but it turns out if i do this we get an
81
accuracy still left so even if we're
trying to predict
explicit masculine feminine words
this debiasing trick sure it removes
some predictive power
but to call this debiased will be wrong
so right now you might be confused you
might wonder well we saw the cosine
distances go down
so why isn't the accuracy much lower
it's actually kind of easy to give an
explanation for that but to do that we
have to
consider what happens when we do this in
not two but
three dimensions what i've got here is a
three-dimensional plot of some clustered
points
and let's say that we have a gender axis
that's known up front
you see a lot of dots and they're also
colored along this gender axis
so let's say we've got one end over here
where everything is dark green
and on the side here it's more light
green so to say
if we were now to perform the trick that
we just did
but now in three dimensions we wouldn't
be projecting onto a line we would be
projecting onto a plane
and in particular would be this one all
of these points will be moving down
and they will be they will be plotted on
this plane
again by using the same argument because
as far as this gender axis is concerned
if you put a dot down here
the gender axis value would remain zero
and to be specific here's what it looks
like
you can notice that the z-axis over here
is super flat
and you see that all of those points are
smushed onto this flat plane
and of course because all of these
points are now on this plane we can
assume that a lot of these cosine
distances are different
but now let's think about what a
classifier actually does
a classifier doesn't look at cosine
distance
typically a classifier looks more at
geometric distance
so let's say that in this space we had a
classifier let's say
then this is a classifier that will be
able to separate points on this side
from this one quite effectively and
the decision boundary that we have over
here
you would still be able to apply that on
this flat
shape smushing points together like this
doesn't mean that the clusters
suddenly are broken into bits it might
happen but you don't necessarily have
this as a guarantee
and it's this phenomena that makes
debian incredibly hard
again we are not learning the meaning
behind a word
we are learning how a word is being used
and that's what's making all of these
clusters appear
and we need more than linear algebra and
some arithmetic
on vectors to add meaning there
but speaking on arithmetic and vectors
there is this other phenomenon
that we should discuss before we wrap up
you might have heard of this thing
called
word analogies and the most common
analogy
in this space is if you take king
you subtract from that man you add a
woman
well then you might be able to say well
because king is to man what queen is to
woman but king minus man plus woman
should equal queen
and when these word embeddings just came
out this analogy property
was heavily marketed people suggested
that there was evidence that
when you trained word embeddings in a
certain way that you might be able to
get these analogies in them
unfortunately though these analogies
they don't seem to hold
in many situations including the famous
king queen one
because the thing that's happening here
is related to the thing that was
happening with the biasing
what what lies allows me to do is it
allows me to fetch the most
similar and below here i've got king
that i'm putting into the system
and what i'm doing now is i'm saying
could you based on cosine distance get
me the nearest tokens
and we see kings and queen and what i
can do is i can say well
i don't want to have the embedding for
king i want to have the embedding for
king minus man plus woman and i want to
get the tokens that are most similar to
wherever i end up there and when you run
this
something interesting is happening so
let's zoom in a bit
it seems that when you do king minus man
plus woman
that the most similar token isn't
queen it's still king
and to make matters worse if you look at
the distance from
king to queen here and if you look at
the distance from
queen to this vector here
then it seems that we're even further
away
so this claim doesn't seem to hold at
least not for
fast text spacey and bypair those are
the languages that i've been trying this
on
now what you could do is you could say
well i'm not interested in cosine
distance i want to use euclidean
but the moment that you do that you get
the same result
the numbers are different but also here
king is on top and the distance for
queen has actually
increased so something really fishy is
going on here
and i can repeat this exercise for not
king and queen but maybe for host
and here again we kind of see the same
thing hostess here
is closer to host than wherever we end
up
after we apply the plus woman minus man
arithmetic
so then we gotta ask ourselves you know
what is actually happening when we do
minus man and plus woman and maybe in
this case we should
not even consider that it might have
anything to do with meaning
but let's just now think about clusters
instead we saw before with the whole
fairness topic that it was
quite useful to think about these word
embeddings in terms of clusters
so let's do that again here now what i
think is happening
is man over here that's probably in the
same cluster
as this token here so then
mathematically
what happens if i take one vector from
that cluster
and i take another vector from that
cluster i'm going to add one vector
and i'm going to subtract the other then
odds are that these two vectors just
cancel
each other out if two vectors that are
similar are being subtracted from each
other
what you end up with is perhaps just a
little bit of noise and then
what's the result going to be well it's
mainly just going to be
the word that i started with and that
means that we can go back to our king
queen example
and maybe start playing around what if
we subtract fast
and add slow well
we gotta squint our eyes a little bit
but just from glancing at it
it really seems that i'm just keeping
the same words here intact
so the most likely thing that's
happening here is again that
we are just adding and subtracting two
terms that cancel each other out
and i hope that this final example
demonstrates that we shouldn't think of
these word embeddings
as a representation of the meaning of a
word
so let's wrap up this talk i thought it
would be a good idea to
do that in the morning as opposed to in
the evening and then in the morning
i shaved and i forgot that that causes
an inconsistency in the video
sorry about that but we've been talking
about these word embeddings for a while
in this video and there's lots of
properties about them
however i would like to end with some
advice if you're going to be using these
embeddings
for your chat bots and digital
assistants
you can wonder if i've got embeddings
that are trained on wikipedia
are they really going to represent
language like how it's being used inside
of a chatbot
wikipedia is pretty formal and usually
about the past tense
while conversations that you have with a
chatbot are present
tense and usually really informal with
lots of spelling errors
so what can you do in these situations
well what you can also do
is you can say instead of predicting the
next token and getting an embedding out
that way
what i can also do is just maybe
predict the intent instead
and that way what you'll get is you'll
get
a representation in the middle of your
neural network
that's still an embedding but it's not
trained on all of wikipedia
instead it's trained on your specific
use case and it was surprising at first
but i have seen
many digital assistants perform pretty
well actually
without using any embedding whatsoever
what these assistants typically do
instead
is they focus in on data quality and
given that you have representative data
it seems that you're better off just
trying to focus in on
that you might not need something that's
heavy and pre-trained
anyway having said all that thanks for
listening if you're interested in
more detailed explanations of material
i've presented today
definitely check out the algorithm
whiteboard and if you want to
investigate what lies in your word
embeddings
feel free to pip install what lies
thanks for listening